[Música]
en
1984 dos trabajadores descubrieron un
cuerpo en un pantano en cheshire
Inglaterra los oficiales llamaron al
cuerpo el hombre del lindow y
determinaron que había sufrido serias
heridas como un traumatismo fuerte y
estrangulación pero lo más impactante de
toda esta macabra historia fue que
pudieron determinar todo eso en un
cuerpo de más de 2000 años de antigüedad
normalmente la descomposición hace
difícil detectar tales heridas en un
cuerpo enterrado unas semanas Entonces
cómo se conservó también este cadáver y
por qué no todos los cuerpos se
mantienen así las respuestas a estas
preguntas yacen casi 2 m bajo tierra no
parece haber mucha vida aquí pero una
cucharadita de tierra contiene más
organismos que seres humanos en el
planeta desde bacterias y algas hasta
hongos y protozoos el suelo es hogar de
una cuarta parte de la biodiversidad del
planeta Y quizá los habitantes más
importantes sean los
microbios organismos no más grandes que
cientos de nanómetros que descomponen el
material orgánico muerto y
moribundo Imagine que deja caer una
manzana en el bosque Tan pronto toca la
tierra los gusanos y otros invertebrados
comienzan a romperla en pedacitos
absorben nutrientes de lo que consumen y
excretan el resto esta primera etapa de
la descomposición prepara la escena para
los microbios los microbios específicos
presentes dependen del entorno por
ejemplo en pastizales y campos de
cultivo tiende a haber más bacterias que
son buenas para romper pastos y hojas
pero en estos bosques templados hay más
hongos capaces de romper materiales
leñosos complejos para cosechar más
alimento de los restos de la manzana los
microbios liberan enzimas que activan
una reacción química llamada oxidación
esta rompe las moléculas de de la
materia orgánica libera energía carbón y
otros nutrientes en un proceso llamado
mineralización luego estos microbios
consumen algunos nutrientes mientras que
moléculas excedentes de nitrógeno azufre
calcio y otros se quedan en el suelo
conforme los insectos y gusanos comen
más de la manzana se expande el área
para que las enzimas microbianas oxiden
y mineralen incluso las excreciones que
dejan son minadas por los microbios esto
continúa hasta que la manzana se reduce
a nada un proceso que tomaría de uno a
do meses en un bosque templado ambientes
calientes y húmedos sustentan a más
microbios que aquellos lugares fríos y
secos lo que les permite descomponer
cosas más rápido y los materiales
orgánicos menos complejos se rompen más
rápido pero con el tiempo suficiente
toda la materia orgánica se reduce a
nutrientes minerales microscópicos los
enlaces atómicos entre estas moléculas
son demasiado fuertes para romperse más
es así que estos nutrientes entes
alimentan la vida vegetal lo que crea
más alimento que con el tiempo se
descompondrá este ciclo constante de
creación y descomposición sustenta toda
la vida en la tierra Pero hay unos pocos
ambientes demasiado hostiles para estos
multitalentos microbios como son los
pantanos A las afueras de cheshire
Inglaterra los pantanos se componen
principalmente de musgo de turbera
altamente ácido estas plantas acidifican
la tierra mientras que liberan un
compuesto que enlaza al nitr
lo que priva de nutrientes al área
aunado a las frías temperaturas del
norte de Europa estas condiciones hacen
imposible que los microbios funcionen
sin nada que pueda descomponerlo el
musgo muerto se apila evitando que el
oxígeno entre al pantano el resultado es
un sistema naturalmente sellado
cualquier materia orgánica que entre al
pantano se queda ahí como el hombre de
lindow el ácido del Pantano fue lo
suficientemente fuerte para disolver
material relativamente simple como el
hueso y ennegrecer tejido más complejo
como la piel y los órganos pero el
cadáver quedó Tan bien conservado que se
pudo determinar que era saludable tenía
veintitantos y posiblemente era rico
pues su cuerpo tenía pocas señales de
trabajo pesado Incluso se conoce la
última comida del hombre del lindow un
pedazo de Pan quemado por digerir no se
conocen con certeza la circunstancias de
su muerte mientras que un asesinato a
sangre fría Es una posibilidad la
severidad de sus heridas sugiere un
sacrificio ritual incluso hace 2,000
años hay evidencia de que el Pantano se
conocía por sus cualidades casi
supernaturales un lugar en el que la
tierra debajo de los pies no estaba ni
muerta ni
viva durante gran parte de la historia
de la humanidad los muertos no se
enterraban Entonces cómo se convirtieron
los cementerios en lo que son hoy
descúbralo con este video o use una guía
para explorar el Inframundo con este
video sobre el libro egipcio de los
muertos